like we're hardcore Gamers all of us  but the Casual when you added marketing  rights the casuals associate that as  almost like an exclusive right because  you see the PlayStation logo on the  bottom Call of Duty and then like Luca  eloquently put out  they've been known  had this map have this content have this  I mean look we come from the destiny  days we yeah we know how bad it is man  we know how bad it is you ain't getting  that Hawk boom you ain't getting the  maps oh what Destiny 2 come out okay now  you guys the bills die every day B I  feel that so they've been known to play  this game with that so that's the  hypocrisy part I have to give you all  that that is literally their entire  business model is that alone is dance  moves I love look uh